hello everyone and welcome to the last
session of these wonderful two days I
hope you had a great time I'm here to
talk about artificial emotional
intelligence social systems and the
future of collaboration with this fine
team of experts that we've assembled
here I'm not going to read this to you
but this is the topic that I actually
asked all of them to look at so we all
know that AI is going to be evolving
into more and more of our everyday lives
and especially our workday lives and our
collaboration lives and so what we were
looking at how do we unpack perceptions
around how emotional intelligence can be
realized within AI systems to make them
more human-like and so that's what each
of these folks are going to be talking
about but from their own angle of
expertise and if you don't feel like
that has been addressed very well
throughout the session we're gonna have
a long time for Q&A where you can follow
up on anything these these people say
here and also ask them further questions
and if not we will talk amongst
ourselves because we enjoy each other's
company so much so I'm gonna go ahead
and introduce each of these speakers one
by one our first speaker would be Marc
Ackerman he's from the University of
Michigan he's got a couple fun facts
he wrote algorithms for bouncing fruit
and ghosts for atari 2600 ms pac-man but
he also knows how to outrun grizzly
bears so you might want to ask him about
that as well
next step we'll have Cindy de Mello he's
from University of Colorado Boulder his
fun fact is that he loves to cook and
can cook many different kinds of
cuisines which is a great follow up here
with Gloria since Gloria Marc from UC
Irvine actually ate a tarantula in
Cambodia and I don't know she has some
tips for Sydney but maybe she could help
him out with that one then yeah we have
Owen Whelan from national university of
ireland galway and his fun fact is that
he used to be he competed for Ireland
and Cycling World Championships just
last year so he's a strong one and we
got another sporty guy here Steve
Whitaker University of Santa Cruz
University of California at Santa Cruz
and he's to play a left winger for his
college soccer team so
all very fit I'm Mary Shaw in ski for
Microsoft Research I ran a group called
human understanding and empathy or hue
and I'll be moderating this session but
for now I think we can have Marc come on
up and give us his point of view should
we stand oh yeah you can okay yeah hi
thanks for attending I am Marc Ackerman
as advertised I can't
by the way I cook or play sports but
what I want to talk about today anyway
is collaboration and some of you know
cool some of you know my paper on the
socio-technical gap I've been thinking a
lot about that and how to extend it into
the new world and this is a great
opportunity to think about some of those
issues what are what's AI going to look
like when we think about what the
difference is between what's technically
feasible and what's organizationally are
socially workable so you know I'm gonna
give a little caveat which is normally
we think about unanticipated
consequences most predictions are of
course mood especially if we go out past
a year or two but having said that since
I'm an academic I will make predictions
anyway that was a joke I sometimes have
to tell my students that I told you so
I do want to say that we have some work
a lot of artificial emotional
intelligence is often about detection of
emotions I along with Walter lisicki and
a student have a system where we're
looking for emotionally manipulative
language particularly in news right now
so I just wanted to say that we are
working on those kinds of issues from a
technical viewpoint and but I want to
draw out what some of the changes might
be so we know that a I for example will
change what I call the expertise
networks you can think about that as an
actor network where the nodes have
expertise and the edges are interaction
strength I think primarily about
expertise sharing it's going to be a
really interesting change when the
machinery of the world or the objects of
the world have some embedded
intelligence and of course things like
books already do
these are going to be interactive kinds
of nodes these will lead to new forms of
of organizing so one great example this
was a flash organizations by the
Stanford people and that was presented
in 2017 at KY so let's think about some
future possibilities here so one is that
the known metrics could in fact include
motivation level those could be detected
by an emotional AI we could also start
to think about motivated reasoning
scores so these might be things like
what are your prejudices what can I
present to you that you will ignore well
how can I get you to stop ignoring those
but also how can i reinforce those
prejudices we can imagine some socially
very problematic things may occur and
you can imagine a network that starts to
make organizational adjustment so you
can you can think of the organization
starting to motivate the individuals but
you can also think about the
transformations and organizational
characteristics and their network such
that they start to play with the
motivated reasoning and I'm sure there
will be some social questions about that
later so one of the things that I've
been thinking about are these really
dramatic changes potentially an agency
so there's I want to introduce something
from computer-supported cooperative work
which is the differences in work so
there's capital W work which is labor so
that's what you think of when you think
primarily work but there's also small W
work which is interactional work so that
can include articulation work which is
coordination work or it can be emotional
work so that's the work that nurses do
for example and there are many many of
these things one of the things that's
happening in CSD W is where we're kind
of collecting the different kinds of
interactional work right now it's
largely invisible so at least our call
this invisible work but this is the work
that makes work work and it's often
things and we don't think of we don't
organizational and reward necessarily
but it's absolutely essential to keep
things going so I do studies in a
hospital if you don't have emotional
work the whole place collapses if you
don't have coordination work the whole
thing collapses none of that is actually
measured and one of the things that's
interesting about a moe
channel a is is this may lead to people
not really being able to understand what
either the labor is that they're
supposed to be doing but even more
importantly the kind of interactional
work that they're supposed to be doing
so what kind of work do we have to do to
understand what the machine can do and
what it can't do and where it has
problems and so this is a may be
perceived or may be a real instability
in both capital W work I would claim and
small W work so those of you that are
American will know the story of John
Henry John Henry is a folktale in
American and he was a person who you
know when people were starting to use
steam engines to actually drive ty
railroad ties into and and tie things
down tie the rails down he was someone
that you know did a hammer and hit the
nail on the head as it were and the
story is that he decided that he would
beat out the e steam engine the the
steam piledriver and he did so but then
he died at the end and you can take
whatever moral you want out of that but
one of the things that I find I find
this folk tale particularly interesting
there's lots of variants of it but it's
a situation where you know none of us in
this room probably think that your work
you know what work is doesn't involve
hitting steel against steel right our
notions of what work is capital W work
has have really shifted and I would
probably argue that small W work is also
shifted so this is gonna lead to a lot
of what I claim in potential
instabilities if you think that we're
undergoing transformations that are
socially and politically problematic
wait and so I want to go back to kind of
the past as it were and I really like
Rondo or lacrosse skis classic learning
from notes and one of the things he says
is how to think about the introduction
of technology so many of you are
probably too young to remember when
collaboration technology showed up
particularly Lotus Notes and Lotus which
is now IBM
no it's they had no idea how to explain
what collaboration was possible with the
system it was really amazing and so one
of the things that she discovered is in
organizations you really have to think
about the technology and how it's gonna
be introduced the goal is that the
different actors might vary so there's
gonna be multiple things that have to be
dealt with in terms of Technology
introduction and particularly I think
for emotional AIS we're gonna have to
really think about the mental models
that users might need to be able to even
use the technology and with that I'll
turn it to the next view all right
Sydney okay so I'm going to set up a
contrast between using sensors to sense
emotions mood stress and behavior and
using ethnographic techniques which is
essentially human observation so
ethnography can get a really deep rich
sense about what's going on with an
individual it enables us to answer the
the how and the why it gives contextual
information so we can give self reports
if we're using sensors to sense behavior
these of course are subject to bias
either they're done infrequently so
there's there's a big gap here and so I
want to talk about I'm gonna give an
example of two projects using sensors
and then I'm going to talk about some
challenges so the first is the test rate
project this is a large-scale project
Sydney is on the project
Erin struggles in the project and what
what we did in this project is use
sensors use a suite of different sensors
collect data from information workers we
did this for one year for 750 people and
we did this across the entire country
and this is a heat map that shows where
people were located and the goal was to
be able to sense workplace performance
but also to be able to send stress and
emotion and behavior
that might be associated with it so if
we're collecting data over the course of
a whole year you know we can we can get
these longitudinal dynamics so we can
look at things like seasonal effects we
can look at the effects of vacation
effects on travel so again you know
potentially there's a lot that can we
learn from this kind of data and I want
to I want to show examples of what this
data looks like so the red line is data
from one individual the blue line is is
the average across the entire sample of
750 people the Green Line is the average
from the organizational cohort that this
person is from and you can see so first
of all heart rate variability is a
measure of stress the lower the value of
the HRV the more stressed a person is
and if we look at this individual we see
that in September and October this
person was more stressed compared to the
rest of the year this is another
individual and we can look at sleep
duration sleep is associated with mood
and also with stress and so for this
individual we see something's going on
here in August September October they're
they're not getting much sleep relative
to the rest of the year looks like
they're getting between 5 & 6 hours of
sleep so something is going on here
and this is yet another individual's
data and here it's a measure of sleep
depth which is the accumulation of loss
of sleep and here we see an interesting
cyclic pattern where the person
accumulates sleep debt and then they get
sleep to recoup okay this is another
project using another way to capture
stress and this is through thermal
imaging and this works really well with
computer tasks because it involves a
camera while a person sits at their
office desk
it's unobtrusive it
very accurate and it basically uses
looks at the area and the paranasal
region of the face to detect stress and
here's two examples on the left side
this is an individual who is highly
neurotic as measured by the Big Five
personality and on the right this is a
person who's only slightly neurotic so
now I want to talk about some challenges
that that we face when we use this kind
of sensor data so first of all but you
know there are conversations as to what
should be considered ground truth if a
person perceives that they're
experiencing stress but the
physiological signal shows that they're
not or vice versa what signal should we
use if they align that's fine but what
happens when these two signals don't
align remember you know perceptions can
be subject to all kinds of biases
another challenge is the limited
contextual information that we get from
sensors so we can detect if a person for
example is at their office desk but if
they're not at their desk we don't know
how to interpret it what are they doing
we are they at a meeting or at a work
break so there's very limited contextual
information that can be gained now you
can instrument instrument an entire
workplace but then this sets up all
kinds of bigbrother kinds of issues so
ethnography enables us to really get a
fairly deep sense of what a person's
experience is in the workplace and I've
done ethnography so what's really
interesting is to understand these
higher-order constructs things like
work-life balance or when a person is
resilient to some sort of bad vent that
happened but sensor data just provides
pretty low-level signals right and so
it's a challenge can you somehow combine
the sensor data
- way that we might be able to get an
understanding of work-life balance it's
really a difficult challenge in last I
want to talk about privacy so we can
address security of data privacy of data
and and we do that in all our projects
but what's also really important is to
address perceived privacy concerns so an
individual may perceive that their data
is not private and so it's really
important we haven't solved this
completely yet we we do things like we
present the data streams that are being
collected to people so that they are
completely aware of what's being
collected who has access to it and so on
but this is such sensitive data that we
really have to go above and beyond that
to really make sure people have have
comfort and the data that's being
collected and really have perceptions
that their data is private all right
thank you
next everyone okay so I've only one
slide just want to talk about one image
essentially so what I'm going to talk
about is a neural adaptive systems so
these are technologies that can detect
neuro physiological processes and
respond automatically so for example
like Gloria is talking about it could be
a system that detects thermal imaging
and detects that you're under stress or
maybe that you're in a mind one removed
and we want you to be creative so what
can the system do to help you
automatically enhance that it might
start playing some ambient music or
change the presentation the layout of
the screen to help you maintain that
particular stage or maybe the system
true facial expressions might sense that
you're in a very focused state you might
have a deadline June 30 minutes and this
is not a good time to interrupt you you
have some emails and some social media
commenting but they can wait until your
state changes
so that's what neural adaptive systems
about and this summit is all about
technologies of the future so it's
likely these technologies will be cedar
we into the workplace in the very near
future so what I'm thinking about is I'm
sure we all know this image up here is
Janice the Roman God or gold war and
peace and so that symbol is used to
represent a duality and it's useful to
think about digital technology in terms
of a duality very often the designers
create technology for very worthy causes
like reducing our stress like helping us
be more productive like helping us be
better at collaboration but because
we're all different with different
motivations and psychological needs and
different personalities we use the with
the technology in a way that sometimes
we have unintended consequences
sometimes those consequences can be
positive and sometimes it can be
negative so for example earlier this
year we did a study of athletes and how
they use fitness tracking technology so
some of you that are runners or cyclists
you might be familiar with apps like
Strava and runtastic and nightclothes so
what we found in our study is that some
athletes they perceive and use the
fitness apps in a way some of them at
least that enhances their harmonious
passion further sport and that's
associated with less life burnout and it
spills over into the workplace in terms
of positive workplace performance but
for other people they use the same
fitness apps in a ways that promote an
obsessive passion for their sport and
that is associated with a higher life
burnout and less workplace performance
or negative workplace performance and
also those people who are a bit more
obsessive and they're more likely to
give up using the app which is obviously
not what the developers originally
wanted to think about so it's useful at
this stage to think about the Janus
effect or the unintended consequences of
neuro adaptive systems so let's just
have some ideas about that it might see
the conversation later on so one
particular consequence might be that
users of these systems might become over
reliant on the technology to tell them
how they actually feel if they're
stressed or happy or anxious or whatever
that might be
and that might not necessarily be a good
thing we just become too reliant on the
technology and just as a kind of an
anecdote of that outside of work I do a
little bit of coaching in in sport in
cycling and a1 athlete it's really
talented but lately it's not really
performing as good as they should and my
intuition was that it's a recovery and
sleep wasn't what it should be so when I
asked this guy about his sleep patterns
which should have been a 10-second
answer he couldn't answer me he had to
go and start looking at his Fitbit and
analyzing data and yeah and I think
that's neat even though it's an anecdote
I think we see that a lot with the
quantifiable movement we expect the
technology to tell us how we feel so
it's all about you know using the best
of human capabilities with the best of
the technology and overall that will
give hopefully a better outcome in terms
of performance and well-being and all
the good things that are interested in a
second area to be thinking about in
terms of the future so that we can
design better technology or preempt some
of the potential negative unintended
consequences is this idea of a filter
bubble rolling over into neural adaptor
systems so if the system tells us that
certain meetings during the week when we
come out of them we feel really down or
unhappy we might be a bit stressed we
might learn over time to avoid those
particular meetings or avoid certain
people or avoid certain situations and
that's not necessarily a good thing
quickly and stress for example we kind
of think stress is a bad thing but
stress can be a good thing as well so
we're kind of only expose ourselves to
situations that the system tells us is
actually good for our emotions and good
for our well-being and we're losing out
then what makes us human about our
experience as well so that could be a
particular danger as well just finally I
guess linking into the Stanley's work in
the education field I was reading
recently that was the University in
China they have cameras installed in
monitor lecture halls something similar
like this that detects facial expression
of the students whether they're engaged
or bored or whether the mind is
wandering and the instructor like me
will have a screen telling me how people
are actually affected by my talk and I'm
supposed to react in real-time
if you're bored that I do a song and a
dance or something
like that so I think that could be a
slight danger as well as similar to the
quantifiable self movement that we start
looking and targeting things that we can
quantify that we can actually measure so
even though other students not might not
be engaging with my material this is
actually the material that's good for
them this is the one this is challenging
this is what they need to think about
that will help them be a high performer
in the workplace whereas if I just
target the things that keep them happy
and keep them engaged that might not
necessarily be the best thing for them
so there are some of my thoughts thank
you thank you thank you very much I want
to talk today about emotion regulation
as opposed to emotion recognition which
is often the topic when we talk about
how emotional technologies might be
deployed so what I want to do first of
all is I want to make some arguments as
to why we should be interested in this
version the problem then I'm going to
talk about two actually contrasting
challenges with the deployment of this
kind of technology
the first being people are apathetic
about it and the second being that
people are over accepting a bit and
we've heard something already about
people treating algorithms quotes too
seriously then I want to give an example
from our own work about a method that we
think has been rather successful in
actually addressing those dual problems
okay so why emotion regulation so I
think there's quite a lot of work that
shows that people don't have a great
deal of insight into their emotions so
if you look at Danny Gilbert's work some
very interesting demonstrations that
when you ask people about how they're
likely to feel in the future they
overestimate the influence of past
recent negative events when you ask
people to regulate their emotions the
majority of people are not very good at
this and one of the reasons is this
phenomenon of negative emotional priming
so if I'm in a terrible mood what that
does is that promotes negative thoughts
and negative memories and that makes it
difficult for me to extricate myself
from that in
situation but perhaps most importantly
for this line of work
there's a lot of evidence that suggests
that people have good emotion regulation
strategies have better physical health
they're more engaged a more profitable
social relationships and they do better
in the workplace okay so they've been a
loss of systems you know if you go and
kind of randomly search on the App Store
you'll find probably over 90,000
well-being apps and some sizeable
sub-segment of those are emotion
regulation apps and the goal of these
kind of apps is they have people usually
by self-report report their moods on the
basis of prompts and then talk about
activities that they've been engaged in
with a hope that what the system can do
is help them better understand the
relationship between the way they feel
and the things that they've done so
unfortunately we're not seeing amazing
runaway success with these types of
applications as I said there are two
general contrasting reactions to them
so the first apathy and skepticism so
the majority these monitoring tools are
downloaded and never used even if
they're slightly used then they're
abandoned after three months and so what
studies have shown is that what people
say about these kind of tools is rather
damningly they offer no insight they're
not useful and basically the analytics
are overly complex so that's the blonde
hand on the other hand we have different
systems which tend to be more kind of
sensor based and this I'm going to
describe some of our own work where
basically what we're seeing is somewhat
strangely participants seem to defer to
algorithmic interpretations their
emotions so we've done some work on
galvanic skin response which is
basically sweat detection using a sensor
and we've looked at it in the context of
systems or algorithms that detract
detect stress and focus so we do various
cognitive tasks with people using these
systems and then as part of the debrief
we ask people how what the
think of the algorithm so here are some
kind of fairly funky exit interview
comments people say things like it could
tell me about an emotion that I don't
know that I'm feeling I feel like this
isn't something that we can actually
track keep track of on our own
somebody sir else says it unlocks a part
of my experience that I'm typically
curious about now this is this is good
because part of what the quantified self
vision is about is helping us to
understand ourselves better but I'm kind
of sensing a bit of a problem since we
have algorithms with errors when they're
being invested with these this kind of
amazing omniscience okay so what we've
tried to do is is to take a rather
different approach with a couple of
goals so what we want to do with our
approach is we want to overcome this
kind of skepticism and apathy by
offering people actionable insights from
data and we want to make people more
skeptical of the system's at the same
time by actually providing them with a
example information about how the
underlying models are working and
allowing them to kind of test those
underlying models this is based around a
psychological theory of habit which is
implementation intentions okay so this
is our system and basically it's got two
components I don't know whether I can
point with this thing but basically if
you look at the top right then what
you'll see the first part of the system
is diagnostic use the system it's like
experience sampling so basically would
that give you a mood prompt multiple
times per day and they would ask you so
you say I'm feeling great and then it
says have you eaten well have you slept
have you exercised and various questions
about your work so after people have
been using this system for about two
weeks we can actually build a pretty
accurate model which relates those
activities to to people's move that's
not a very novel diagnostic part of the
Syst
I want to talk about what's the more
novel part of the system which is the
part on the bottom right so let me just
talk about what the system here does so
what it does is we use mu data pass mu
data to make predictions about future
mood so if you look on Monday we've made
a prediction about how you're likely to
feel tomorrow and if you look above
Monday we've used the model that we've
built to make two implicit
recommendations our Netflix about things
that you could do to improve your mood
so what this says is for this user if
you plan a healthy eating activity or a
healthy social activity that will boost
your mood what the system asks you to do
is to explicitly plan those activities
if you plan them you see the graph
changes you get a mood boost so the idea
is that were exposing two people the
model about the relationship between
what they do and how they feel right and
we're also explicitly asking them to
shed you all that okay I'll be quick so
we do this we improve people's mood we
do this we improve people's
self-efficacy with respect to strategies
that they can undertake to improve their
mood in other words people will believe
that they're more effective at
moderating their mood and they have more
effective strategies for doing that so I
can talk more about these Canada points
and we've done this we've replicated
this result several times okay so that's
just to summarize what I just said thank
you very much all right now supposedly
we have mic runners somewhere in the
room and yes okay we have paddles who
has questions okay we have a question
right here
so going back to the Lucy fortune the
University of Minnesota so I'm trying to
put together the sort of tutorial
information that we saw and and the
emotional responses and and it so if one
of the overarching ideas and all of this
is to try to help people learn better by
potentially using their facial cues or
what have you
learning can be painful so you know I
guess the idea is that you're going to
draw some conclusions about you know to
correlate the emotional response to
learning and and use that or I guess I'm
not understanding how that would work
and I hope you understood my question
yeah sure
so a couple of things learning can be
painful and in conceptual information
one of the key emotions that moves
learning is that of confusion because
it's a signal that you don't understand
something so in the past we've actually
worked on our tutoring system that tries
to sense if you are confused frustrated
or bored and users tries to think about
strategies accordingly to react and the
point of and we've have some effects in
some conditions it's far from set in
stone but the point is that in all of
those assessments are assessed
assessments of those emotions themselves
are so noisy and the question is at one
point people would tell us you just
fools you can never do anything with
those types of weak assessments and we
actually would try to show that the way
you the way you I would never say you're
confused right I would actually maybe
offer you a hint if I thought you were
confused or leave you confused for a bit
but if you're in there for too long I
might then give you a hint so the point
is we do what I want to make is that
done epically and responsibly with some
transparency with rather weak models
which many times is going to be the
reality one can actually have
interesting outcomes I think there's a
question back here pedal - yes I'm
really interested in the ability to
model emotions and work or or work that
has a lot of emotional content and in
particularly negotiation which happens
in both formal and informal ways
constantly organizations which sort of
leads to sort of our ability to
collaborate or not and and I'm wondering
if the the distinction between being
able to actually recognize when emotion
is occurring in a given conversation
versus the ability to support
negotiation and the kind of things that
AI does well in terms of search and
matching patterns with you know
information with a specific outcome that
you could actually you can actually get
a you get far if you can do marry that
content with just some little nudges
around emotionality as opposed to trying
to read in in in depth what people are
feeling like if I'm in the middle of a
negotiation a tool has knowledge that
that there is there's something that I
haven't put on a table that's important
for me to actually engage with in this
particularly negotiation and voices are
being raised or my heart rate is up then
there could be an intervention there I
think that would be effective without
being about reading the entire situation
any thoughts on that I'm negotiation is
such a critical aspect of organizational
life and I just don't see and I haven't
seen a lot of marrying our technology
with that particular aspect can take
that one so sandy Pentland quite a few
years ago did us did a system called
honest signals and we actually decided
to rebuild that and put that in Skype
and kind of experiment with it but the
signals were for the users eyes only
just to show themselves
how much they were talking over the
other person how consistent they were
being how much mimicry they were using
etc and it was very interesting we've
continued to build build on this kind of
system people sometimes intentionally
hide their emotions for very good reason
and so that's why we believe in giving
you the signals back of how you're
behaving
people especially liked the signals of
I'm talking too much or I'm talking over
the other person too much so what we saw
there was in negotiations and in trying
to convince each other of certain things
we saw people behaved a little bit
better but showing them too many signals
was actually detracted from the
conversation so I think we have to get
better at choosing which signals would
actually be effective during a
conversation or a group conversation
where they're trying to negotiate and I
think there's still a lot more work that
needs to be done there we're actually
doing a little bit of work on trying to
design for more inclusive and diverse
meetings with more positive outcomes and
that's been really challenging but super
excite 'fl if we can make it happen but
I agree with you that you could
definitely you could do some automated
searches or whatnot if there was
confusion or a lack of lack of clarity
of communication or something that could
probably help all the parties that that
are at the table I think that's a really
useful idea yeah and can I just build on
that for a second so I think a lot of
the research on emotions has taken the
primary the work on primary emotions I
think too seriously so there's a loss of
cross-cultural work which basically says
there's a basic set of primitive
emotions and what the goal of emotional
algorithms and analytics should be is to
recognize whether somebody is fearful or
surprised what I like about your
suggestion is that what you're
suggesting is not necessarily trying to
arrive at some accurate interpretation
of the semantics of the particular class
of emotion but rather you're saying that
there is some emotion involved I think
we have much more chance of getting that
correct and it might be an interesting
thing to leave it to the participants
set to actually negotiate
under those circumstances how they want
to deal with that without as being tied
to you know make some possibly
inaccurate inference that it was fear
versus you know confusion let's say so I
think that's a very promising idea and
it is consistent with I guess a
different set of theoretical
perspectives on emotion there's a
question here oh wait sorry pedal number
one outlet Schmidt University of Munich
I have a question I think Steve had the
notion of emotion modulation and I think
as we see people are more and more of
your time sort of interacting with their
environment through a device speed at
the moment a mobile device beats out
from network speed we are a are in the
future and and I think one of the big
questions that comes out once we are
there that we can recognize some of the
emotions and we start by yeah changing
the feet we see in our social networks
we modulate people's emotions whether we
want to do it or not we always will
basically which things to be show which
messages to be show we modulate people's
motive people's emotions and so my
question is are we getting into a
business where we say oh this is sort of
the optimal so you should be a bit set
in the morning then to bridge lunch we
make me happy after lunch you're tired
we make you bit sad and towards the end
of the day we make you happy is it sort
of inevitable that we get there and even
if we don't want to we are doing it and
should we consciously do it or should we
stay away from it so I guess the
objective of our system is rather more
to teach people insights and to provide
them with strategies we do not provide
an objective scoring metric and you'll
notice that our work is entirely
subjective right so somebody them said
we asked a person they themselves
weren't using sensors so they're
defining what you know good or bad is
under those circumstances
so really it's it's kind of reflective
that it's - it's showing you the
relationships between what you think of
good or bad emotions and you know what
particular behaviors you've engaged in
that have led to those but I think you
bring up a very good point about whether
or not there's some kind of implicit
optimum that we're all kind of striving
for and I will say that we there is I
don't know whether is James Panabaker
has some very very fine work which is
here in the audience okay well one of
the points that James has some fantastic
work which basically demonstrates that
there are benefits to reflecting on
negative experiences they're quite
profound benefits so I think that we
should not think if we're trying to
design these apps that our emphasis with
our system is on positive experiences
but there are clear benefits empirically
demonstrated benefits to reflecting on
the negative so I think we should think
very clear clear about those criteria
but yeah just quickly Owen do you want
to mention this because this was your
Janus effect right there's a little bit
of that right yeah absolutely and don't
think we we want to get to that
situation where we have some sort of an
optimal there's a score that we're
trying to target every day I don't think
that'll be healthy in the long run we
have to remember yet the Janus effect
that even bad emotions can actually be
good for us in the long run so something
that might be stressful in the short
term going for a job interview or being
you know standing in front of a
presentation like this that can cause a
little bit of stress but it's good in
the long run so that'll be kind of a
yeah one of the concerns or dangers I
would see with these systems strictly
the neuro adaptive ones that we can't
internet filter bubble anchors talking
about area where we only pursued the
happy positive feelings but it's those
tricky things is when we fail and we
were upset and something goes wrong for
us that's how we learn and that's what
makes us human and if we try to avoid
those well that's not a good situation
to be in
go ahead mark yeah I just so I'm playing
Debbie Downer today I think but when I
go back to the social you know it's one
thing if the individual is in control of
their own stuff but it's another thing
if they're living in an organizational
and there's organizational stakeholders
that are maybe trying to manipulate them
or either positively or negatively and
going back to Mary's talk earlier today
that's going to be an interesting
trade-off in terms of the kinds of
technologies that are deployed and under
what conditions yeah
Gloria do you want to say anything about
emotional homeostasis yeah so I actually
talked about this yesterday so there
there is this notion that people have
this drive for inner balance and if you
experience too much negativity you
should in theory have this drive to
experience something more positive to
balance but what this balance is you
know there is no external optimal kind
of balance it's it's really an
individual notion of what balance is and
what what works for the individual and
so I do think that there is a danger for
systems to be potentially telling us
what is this optimal balance when in
fact it may not coincide with what's
right for the individual okay hi I'm
Carolyn Rosa from Carnegie Mellon and I
was particularly interested in this
session because at the end of the title
was the future of collaboration but I it
seems like there's really a very big
focus on individuals and individual
regulation in what you have presented
and so just coming to my own area of
computer-supported collaborative
learning one of my colleague Sanne
uruvela is very famous for making a
three-way distinction in social settings
between individual regulation social
regulation which is where individuals
help each other regulate and group
regulation where the group itself has
practices that keep the group regulated
and I just wonder the extent to which
your message is that it's mainly about
the individual or is it you know so and
is the group just the sum of the parts
or where do these other levels of
regulation fit in to what you've been
presenting yeah we've done some group
work
and on my team looking at creativity for
instance and we definitely have seen
that different personality types and
different patterns of diurnal so for
instance if you're an early bird or a
night owl if you put those kinds of
people together they don't actually like
working together very well on certain
kinds of tests but they actually do way
more creative solutions when they're
together so it's funny how groups will
then start to almost align with each
other and the way they're thinking so
yeah I think these group efforts need to
be studied way more I need to look up
this person your colleagues what was her
name again fine okay we need to do more
studies of that because I thought that
was fascinating how the groups really
didn't like working with each other but
then they started to align and they
started to regulate each other basically
to a better solution which was really
cool to see so there's all kinds of
diversity even when you like to go to
bed I used to do a lot of work with
groups and I can attest to the
variability among groups so you can have
two people who are paired with two other
people you get a totally different group
than if it were two other individuals
that they're paired with so there it's
it's really a tough problem because of
the variability of groups and the fact
is that even though you might be able to
model individual emotions you put people
together in a group and the dynamics
affects the interactions and the
emotional experiences I think even if
you show an individual their own signals
it's going to influence how they then
interact with the group which will then
change the whole group dynamic so we've
been playing with the idea of showing
you your individual signals for how
you're performing and then watching what
that does to the overall group signals
which are anonymized so you don't
actually know who's driving the emotions
that are going on in the room but you
see your signals which makes you behave
differently so it's very it's almost
chicken-and-egg to study this problem to
be honest but I need to talk to you
about how you're doing
so I'm just so - people make inferences
about whose emotional streams they're
saying well if if they see they're
behaving let's say but there's badness
going on in a room yeah then they're
gonna yeah it may it may we'll see it
may make them embolden them to say
something to the room we'll see I also
want to add that studying groups in the
real world is even harder because you
have all these social influences you
have things like career trajectories and
you have power struggles and hierarchies
and so it becomes even more challenging
to be able to figure out emotional
regulation in a group with all these
social forces but I mean I would just
turn it around back to you so do you
think there is kind of like a meaningful
concept of like the group in motion do
you think that's a do you think that's a
thing or do you think it's right to be
talking about individuals do you have a
perspective right I think I am not
entirely sure where I stand on that I
have viewed work from both sides and I
think that there's something to be said
on both sides I guess it's just that and
it might be very difficult to study but
if if we think that what we're going for
is what is the workplace of the future
how is collaboration going to work in
the future just because it's complicated
doesn't mean that we can just restrict
ourselves to studying individuals
because as you're all pointing out even
if we really understood individuals we
wouldn't know how you know really what
we would want to do then in that social
setting because it could have very
unanticipated results because of the you
know unpredictable group level response
to what we're doing at the individual
level so I think we just have to keep in
mind as a field be a little cautious
about where we think this is going in
terms of the workplace because you know
just because we can't study it doesn't
mean that we might not negatively affect
it if we try to intervene at a level
that ignores part of what's happening
another example I have on that topic is
we
we're looking at Microsoft is looking to
move into more and more open spaces and
Gloria and I participated in a study
last summer where we looked at groups
that were in individual offices and
we're staying there groups that were in
open spaces and we're stand had been for
a while and we're staying there and then
we looked at groups that transitioned
from open to closed and just one of the
findings that was quite remarkable about
open spaces everybody says it's great
for collaboration right that's supposed
to be the end goal and what we actually
found was that there was much more
positive effect significantly more
positive effect expressed in the closed
offices than in the open offices and
that was because everybody retreats to
headphones and tries to look like
they're seriously hard-working even when
they're watching TV on their desktop
because and also they didn't want people
to interrupt them so there were more
face-to-face meetings in closed offices
and fewer face-to-face meetings in the
open offices but it was very hard to
study is why I'm bringing it up first of
all you had to agree to have your
emotional signals recorded people around
you knew you're you were having these
recordings going on because we had to
put up signs saying we're do it because
if they came into the camera they were
being recorded even if we could hear you
you were being recorded so we almost had
to get the whole group to do it so it
was very very difficult to recruit for
this work so every time we've tried to
do group emotional work it's been pretty
difficult when you go beyond a dyad but
we're doing it we're gonna figure out
ways to do it over here Jamie finally
okay this is Jamie Pennebaker this is a
great a very nice symposium just because
so many perspectives are introduced one
of the things that has bugged emotion
researchers for the last hundred years
is the idea and James Laird talked about
this at Clark University that we
shouldn't even be talking about emotion
we should use emotion as an adjective
emotional behavior emotional physiology
etc etc the killer problem is something
that Gloria brought up is what is our
what's the gold standard
and and self-reports are lovely but they
are also there's people's self theories
and they are self-reported related to
other self reports biological measures
they're glorious
except the problem is one type of
physiology physiological measure is
often completely uncorrelated with other
types of physiological measures and
we've known these problems for for very
long and I would would ask and Ian
brought this up a little bit which is is
does it make sense for us to be thinking
about the the minute-to-minute emotional
story of a person or even the day-to-day
should we be thinking about a broader
goal stander in terms of how do emotions
affect say important behaviors that a
taxpayer worries about physical health
mental health drug taking you know all
these things that we view as problematic
that shouldn't does it make sense for us
to start thinking about if we do
something what are the or if we bring
about an intervention or we see
emotional changes in whatever domain
we're looking at that the that getting a
hard outcome that we see several days
weeks months perhaps even years later
might be an alternative way to think
about it and and I think in some ways
this gets to what Carolyn was talking
about if you look at the broad swath of
research in terms of what psychological
features are related to say physical
health you know one is is there is some
evidence in terms of this being self
reflective to some degree not too much
but the other is being it is a social
environment that that a very positive
social environment where there's social
support we know is associated with
objective markers of physical health
mental health etc etc anyway so please
answer those questions and get get back
to us all
oh you know that we know that you know
your well-being is definitely correlated
with making money in a corporation so
that's an important one sorry I I think
there I think it's a really interesting
and valid point to be thinking about
significant events that people
experience and emotions that are
associated with this but I think it's
also a question of how how far should
that timeline be right do we look at
what predicts a person's emotion around
the time the event occurred do we go
back to weeks
maybe it's months maybe a person has
been experiencing chronic stress for
quite some time which affects how
they're going to react to that event so
I think it's not exactly clear as to
what that time point should be when you
start to look at emotions to be able to
predict an event
I guess the emotion that I was most
focused on is stress and we often think
that their biological measures are more
objective than just asking people some
psychometric scales turns out they're
quite reliable and very often the
biological measures can be quite biased
so you're measuring things like hormones
so if people there are heavy coffee
drinkers or smoked cigarettes or getting
hormone replacement therapy all those
things people have to be screened out of
studies so I guess the way we've always
approached it is that in terms of stress
anyway you have the psychological
measures and the physiological there are
complements of each other to measure
different things it might not be highly
correlated but overall we get a better
understanding of stress for example at
that particular construct there was no
perfect way to measure a reporter score
on it but when we use different
approaches we get a better understanding
and in terms of the time scale just
general the glory he was talking about
were doing a study or a pilot study at
the moment we're not just looking at the
distress to the person but how that
affects the people around them the
partners in our particular case so how I
use technology in the workplace if
that's causing me stress on a per day
basis
we're able to see that that has an
effect on the partners mood or the
partners the emotions in the evening so
yes over the course of a day at least we
do see that those stress measures do
affect other people in a day how quickly
can you start to see those patterns
emerge is it over a week two weeks we're
still in the pearl of what we've done
over two weeks is what we have so
whether it's probably you're hoping to
get funding for a bigger study so I
think you'll have to go a longer period
of time but we have seen some
interesting results at the two-week
period so can I just ask you are you is
your proposal that we maybe just treat
emotions as some kind of intervening
variable that maybe in the future we
just don't need anymore because we'll
have more accurate of your physiological
/ behavioral measures which will
correlate with measurable outcomes is
that yeah I mean is that what you're
proposing
I'm actually not proposing anything but
what I'm suggesting is well part of it
actually the the weather analogy is
actually a very interesting one is that
here we have all of these different
dimensions and focusing on any one
dimension gives us such a sad view of
kind of the emotional world that perhaps
some kind of broad strategy gets at it
but I guess I'm interested in is to me
an emotional experience an emotional
event takes on value when it brings
about meaningful behavioral change and
so it's it it's not a denial of emotion
or a particular particular issue but if
we just focus just on self-report or
just on skin conductance or just heart
rate variability or just immune system
or etc we know every one of these is
horribly horribly flawed and what
happens is all of us have all gotten
into our different worlds and the longer
in your world you start to start to
believe that your measure is the gold
standard
and there it is the interesting problem
is that all of these are crappy measures
but if this person gets sick or if this
person starts using drugs or this person
goes and shoots somebody those are
pretty good measures of of emotional
dysregulation so it's all beautiful do
we have another question out there well
I have a question for you sleep then
let's go with that one first it's me
again I'm mark I'm really interested in
your your comments around the future the
disconnect between the social system and
technical system advances and and and
our organizations norms and practices
and our capacity actually hold together
when the nodes are smarter essentially
but your your distinction between
[Music]
capital W work and and you know small
letter work and how that might sort of
what's the right word our technical
symptoms won't be able to do the kind of
articulation and coordination work that
you mentioned but I've been presuming in
in terms of what I'm when I'm reading
literature and working on these problems
that a lot of our systems will actually
free us out to do more that work and so
more of the work that we consider that
it's sort of undervalued and unseen will
be free to do more that work and to to
hold us together more tightly but you're
articulating a different dystopia so I'm
curious what you know where do you see
that we do you see that gap coming in
well let me say that actually I build
these systems because I'm intrigued by
them so it's not as though I'm
completely just utopian I was actually
making a slightly different point which
is that I think social instability shows
up when the forms of labour change but
it also shows that
the forms of interactional work change
or the the things that are required so
if I'm dealing with emotionally
intelligent agents suddenly I'm doing
invisible work that I've never done
before and it's not over time as a
society we'll figure out how to deal
with that right so if my car I think we
came up with the analogy if my car just
refused to take me someplace because it
decided it was bad for me I would be
suddenly starting to do kinds of
international work that I don't normally
do over time people would adjust that
was the John Henry thing people in the
society adjusts but I think in the short
term the issue is that I think when both
kinds of instability occur at the same
time it becomes very socially
problematic and it's really a very a
synopsis of very interesting study I
haven't seen the study yet but
apparently someone has done a study of
letters to the to the editor of the New
York Times and around 1900 which is
another point of historical and
stability and the number of conspiracy
grants and those letters is actually
about as high as it is today and so
there are the the the premise is there
are these moments of misinformation and
and which is an indicator of social
instability that occur episodically in
American history or other history
presumably and so I I think that's kind
of one of the issues is how do we
introduce this technology in a way that
doesn't create more instability but
actually allows people to adopt them and
in ways that are reasonable or at least
smooth I don't know if that answered
your question or not hopefully it did so
I could just build on this a little with
with maybe a speculation so it might be
that one of the things that automation
is doing is it's kind of taking bites
out of work with a big w and it
certainly seems that work with little W
is much harder to do because it's kind
of complex and unders under specified an
often interpersonal so maybe that what
we are left with certain
short-term is that people are kind of
filling in the interstitial gaps there
but a lot of the work has been taken
over by by the machines and that that
would be a new situation and that would
be a something that would have to be
negotiated yeah I think that's a really
interesting point and and I think one of
the things that happens historically is
these things become routinized over time
and therefore in some sense the lower
cognitive load and in the meantime we
have to figure out how to to keep for
lack of a better you know I'm sure
you're all quite aware of the politics
of American society at this point
prorack on and you know I bet that's I
think a substantial issue and certainly
in labor relations at least but as far
as I know I've not seen many agents
proposed to do articulation work in CSC
W for example and that might be you know
so sure we've got scheduling agents
right but they they that's a very kind
of limited routinized version of one of
those tasks but you know maybe there's
an interesting opportunity to just think
about what something like that would
look like I'm not saying we'd be very
good at building it but what would that
look like as something that was kind of
automated that did some of this kind of
maybe group smoothing emotional sensing
but also kind of help people kind of
work together kind of greasing the
wheels of collaboration I think's a
really tough ask but it's a very
interesting kind of challenge in terms
of the type of system that we might
think about those mm-hmm that's a really
interesting idea I think all up on that
uh I think that there is it's an
interesting proposition is combining
your two sort of statements and in some
of the things that were said earlier the
ability to actually give people real
sort of real-time feedback on on how
they're experiencing and perhaps giving
them options about how they respond
maybe able to sort of
ease some of that pain in the sense that
you know some of the hardest pain is the
unacknowledged pain right because we're
not actually actively dealing with it
and trying to sort of raise that into
the the forefront of our understanding
so when you're what we're doing
organizational change telling people the
the height of the challenge that they're
about to face while giving them
confidence in the supports for them to
transition and make those change will
help people get through that change but
surprising people with a very
challenging situation that they don't
feel prepared for obviously gives people
a lot of anxiety and higher sense of
risk and you could perhaps do that in a
more real-time fashion a more available
fashion than you can in the way we
operate in organizations today so so it
might be interesting there to kind of
share social signals so you know a kind
of problem shared is a problem halved
you know that's a phrase I just made up
myself just created that one just now -
nothing there but but you could think
there that you might want to use social
signaling in this non private way to
basically indicate to people that
they're not alone in terms of
experiencing a particular difficulty and
again this might speak to Carolyn's
perspective which is if I know that
everybody in my group is equally
confused then you know maybe I don't
feel so bad about declaring that I am
kind of utterly bereft of ideas that
well I agree it so I mean to go to your
point
so if if people have a sense of
confusion and bewilderment at the
introduction of new technology and
they're aware that everybody is I think
that that would be very beneficial
anybody else isn't there
so um so as a follow-up it seems like
there's a big focus in this discussion
about forms of supporting regulation
that involve reflecting back to people
their emotional state and so I wonder
what you think of other forms of
scaffolding an individual and group
situations that might not be about
directly reflecting back people's
emotion but giving suggestions or even
putting practices in place that keep
emotions in check to begin with where do
you think this work fits into that kind
of broader or spectrum of intervention
approaches yeah we're actually trying to
do that now by working working micro
interventions into product in Hawaii so
that everybody gets it I always say
everyone should have gotten
socio-emotional training when they were
kids right but for some reason
organizations don't emphasize that so I
think it's a real big opportunity to get
micro interventions actually into the
workplace and into work itself but as
we've been talking about it's gonna be
super useful for groups as well it's
just the HCI problem is how you do it
without being patronizing and annoying
and and pointing fingers at people right
but I love the idea of suggestions
that's a really good one so I think to
go back to your earlier point there's
this individual perspective and there's
this collective perspective and from an
individual perspective reflections very
powerful from a collective viewpoint it
may be that you change the reward
structures the normative structures and
and that's something where you know if
you're in an organization those are much
easier for the organization to do I
don't think it's it's a duality it's a
you know you if you're in a collectivity
or some sort of you're probably doing
both at the same time
and of course managers do it all the
time I mean you reward your employees
for how collaborative they are and how
they work in groups etc so I mean I
think maybe a point that I took from
what I just saying is maybe we want to
kind of downplay emotions
some points in terms of replacing those
with kind of concrete suggestions or
actions so I want to push back against
that situation because I think there's a
great deal or suggestion rather I think
there's a great deal of work in
psychology which suggests that emotions
are a huge motivator of behavior so
again if you look at the behavior change
behavior modification literature there's
a lot of strong evidence that suggests
that you know emotions are a signal
they're our signal to ourselves to make
a change to behavior and if we just base
it so this might be a push back again
towards the intervening variable
perspective people very often do things
because they want and gender particular
emotional outcomes or because they want
to avoid other competing emotional
outcomes so if this is the adaptive
perspective on emotions and if we just
if we start just cutting out the kind of
intervening variable by just saying
behave in this particular way then I
think we subvert some of the kind of
learning and justification mechanism so
it's very important in our system that
people basically understand consequences
to behavior because that's a motivator
forum right if you don't have that yeah
so just to kind of give you kind of a an
example of what I would see as kind of
scaffolding that actually is something
that I think is I see being put into
practice and lots of organizations and
that is what are ways that we should
talk that create an inclusive
environment and we have these practices
now about how people introduce
themselves how they make their pronouns
clear all these things are supposed to
create an environment in which people
are less likely to offend each other
about their orientation and other kinds
of issues so do you see what you're
advocating as in competition with that
or is that operating at a different
level it certainly does affect emotions
when people are
interacting in ways that are offensive I
think that's I think that's a terrific
example I think the reasoning would go
along the following lines if you want
people to be sensitive about how they
view and judge others you want them to
be aware about the emotional
consequences that their language or
behaviors can have on others so it's
basically it's the same argument as I've
just delivered but applied to other
people so basically what you want to say
is you know call this person him or it
or they because there are emotional
consequences to that person and maybe if
you want to follow through and you
wouldn't like that experience yourself
so I think I think that's that's the way
I would kind of run that particular
argument rather you know what you
wouldn't be saying okay then and just to
test it you know when you're in that
situation call that person she hurt
right yeah that's not the way you say in
principle if you behave in these
particular ways these are the emotional
consequences and you hope that you know
as adults that those the behaviors
follow but I guess they're I guess the
point that I was trying to make really
was that um I'm not I'm not arguing
against the idea that emotions are more
primary and that behavior arises from
them which it sounded like was the
argument for why is it so important to
focus on emotion rather than behavior
because emotion is what's driving a lot
of behavior but I think that we
acknowledge that we understand something
about emotions that drive behavior and
we tried to kind of circumvent that by
putting practices in place instead of
just making it more clear with mood
rings that people I think we are yes yes
so I'm not saying
discover the consequences of misusing
pronouns by seeing how much emotional
mayhem you might cause but I think we
can perspective take right and I think
that's the way the argument goes but you
could have a training class where those
people those you know those people who
might be experiencing bad consequences
arm there where you actually expert
bad emotional consequences yourself
because that's the learning experience
so when you move to the real-world
situation you know the emotions that the
implicit emotions are in place because
you're actually perspective-taking
so it's I think it's not an argument for
removing emotions from the situation
it's an argument for reflecting or
anticipating emotion and bottling of
other people okay I think this was a
wonderful panel that's a cop for all the
panelists
[Applause]